every socialist and I count myself as
one has always been like a stopped clock
that eventually tells the
the right time
um you know we kept uh predicting a
massive Financial collapse ever since I
was you know 10 and it happened in 2008
So eventually you know all our
predictions come true it doesn't mean we
will write analytically about it
um
look uh
why do I think that this time
it's different
to quote famous economists
first
I'll repeat some of the things I said
but in a different manner hopefully
helpfully
take what happened in the summer of 2020
here in London I think it was the 12th
of August when you had the announcement
that your GDP fell by more than 20
percent for the first time in the
history of British capitalism remember
that August 2020. the market
expectations were for a
fall of about 12 to 13 percent
it was much much more than that
and yet 15 16 minutes later the London
Stock Exchange went up that has never
happened before in the history of
capitalism
why did it happen for a very logical
reason
because Market players thought oh my God
20 plus then this immediately
nanoseconds related I thought okay if
we're panicking the bank of England are
panicking so they're going to print
loads of money and they will pump it in
another Direction okay to refloat the
disaster
so let's keep buying
okay now this is simply a little tale
that I tell in order to capture the
manner in which
financial markets have completely
decoupled from real existing capitalism
and if you think about it in 2008 we had
in 1929 Our Generations 1929 the
difference with 1929 was that unlike
the Hoover administration in the United
States in 29 that let the banks fall
uh the G7 G20 April 2009 Gordon Brown
London yeah they decided to refloat them
so they went into a spasm of
printing mountain ranges of money to
refloat the financial markets which they
did very successfully
proof that if they want to do something
they do they do it right but ever since
they did that
uh
and they did it in a staggered way the
European Central Bank really began doing
it in 2012 and then went all out in 2015
with Mario draige first of March but the
way I see it now capitalism has
completely been hooked on Central Bank
money
and therefore why is Jeff Bezos 50
billion dollars richer than he was at
the beginning of the pandemic it's not
the profits of Amazon of his businesses
it is the increase in the German because
what happens is QE means that you know
the Central Bank brings money
they give it they effectively given a
high a larger overdraft to you know the
Barclays Banks Deutsche banks of the
world
they look at you people they say oh no
no we're not going to lend them because
they're hopeless so they pick up the
phone they call Volkswagens emails ask
them you know Google Apple and they say
do you want a few billion those people
don't need money because they already
have stashes of money which itself is a
problem because corporations should be
borrowing not not saving but they take
the money because it's free
and they take it and they go to the
stock exchange and they buy back their
own shares
okay so now you have a bifurcation of uh
of capitalism we have the companies that
maintain profitability because it's not
Monopoly that they have for me Amazon
you know
um
General Motors had a monopoly or an
oligopoly Amazon is different it's a
platform it means that you exit
capitalism you exit the market and you
go into a place that where everything
that's sold or bought are controlled by
one company one algorithm because
there's quite a lot in there and it's
like Julian come out on that QE
quantitative easing money sloshing
airport just one one final just phrase
so
if
if what I'm saying holds water
then atom speed is simply not relevant
he's as relevant as Karl Marx was in the
Soviet Union when he were there in other
words not at all
so you're saying it's not relevant
because the financial markets today
don't tie into the real economy and
because essentially you have platform
monopolies on technology
yes and even the companies that are not
platform companies through private
Equity takeovers they're being taken
over loaded by with debt which is
financialized those companies are then
split up asset stripped so you have this
squeezing of the capital sector
of of what Adam Smith would consider to
be the capital sector you know the
squeezing of it completely until all you
have is central banks on the one hand
financial markets and the platforms so
let me turn around say like this would
you believe that competition is a good
thing in an economy absolutely okay let
me ask four questions do you believe
that prices are useful
do you believe that profits are a good
thing as an incentive and that you
should reinvest profit back into
Ventures
no
but I do believe
wait wait because of you know I've when
you read this you'll see
um there is a chapter in there called
markets without capitalism
right so at in it I try to answer your
question by In This Book I try to create
a blueprint of how how we could have
done things differently this is the book
so in in my in my Utopia in my in this
Utopia in the other now that I call it
uh markets are essential because Iris
the Anthropologist modeled after you
right as you know uh she says that you
know at some point that
um the only thing that stops
uh authoritarianism and a Soviet kind of
Gulag from descending upon us is markets
and competition and freedom freedom of
Enterprise but the problem is that the
the moment you have share markets that
are being effectively
turbocharged through central bank money
and you have the financialization that
you experience and you explain very
nicely in the book then the competition
dies so your basic argument is with
Equity markets and the current form of
equity markets and stockholding
companies if I understand it rightly I
mean let me say this if you believe that
competition is valuable if you believe
that prices matter if you believe in a
diversification of different roles and
specialist functions and that's good I
believe in all that okay well that
doesn't make you sound very socialist
with orbit or due respect well
that is not true
do you remember Oscar Lange
sorry Oscar Lange right do you remember
Oscar London yeah you may need to remind
us
1920s one of Friedrich Von Hayek's great
adversaries the other was John Manuel
Keynes Oscar lanky was a Socialist
Communist actually
who believed in
novice Center he was completely against
the idea of gosling of a central plan
but he was in favor of what effectively
I have tried to
you know to map out in this book
um
a market where let me give you an
example right
imagine a world where
you join a corporation
and you get one share in the same way
that you enroll in University and you
get a library card
and that library card that one share
gives you one vote it allows you to do
stuff borrow books participate in
decision making and so on and then when
you have to leave when you leave you
take your Capital out and you have to
hand over your library card your one
share now
just for the moment go along with this
imagine you have a market
where you have competition between
companies that are owned by those who
happen to work in them
and you have
you when you ask people that I believe
in profits no I don't because if you
have that system you have net revenues
because there is no distinction between
profits and wages everybody profit
shares I mean you're going to chip in
and ask you did say you believed in
competition absolutely diversity so I
understand what you're going to do with
your profits Julian asked you that then
you said and she said that's not
socialist and you said well actually it
is but then I would have got a bit
confused sorry this is a bit
alternative find your confusion of
course but what would you do with the
profits oh you're invest them or you
divide them so let me turn them out let
me give you an example and this is this
is this is a really existing example I
won't mention the company but I've
worked for that company back in 2011
2012. it's in Washington state United
States so imagine look it up look it up
imagine a company where
the revenue
total revenue is divided in four parts
one part is fixed costs you know friends
and servers and stuff the second part is
r d
the third part is a basic income of
everybody working from you know the
janitor or the way to the the arch
designer and the fourth part is bonuses
and imagine that the r d segment
is decided as a result of a vote where
the membered employees vote between
different business plans that are
presented once a year once every two
years
the basic pay the same and then bonuses
are decided on the basis of the
Eurovision song contest scoring system
where every employee gets a hundred
points but you can only distribute them
award them to other people depending on
your understanding your appreciation of
their estimation see the problem is with
your
quite good except Britain would always
lose so you know this is a different
Corporal structure right the company
wants to maximize its revenues
there's no there is competition
but there's no capitalism
and there's no distinction between wages
and profits okay the idea that workers
get skin in the game yes absolutely the
idea they have some checks and balances
and some involvement absolutely the idea
you're going to organize
5500 people into a committee to take it
through decisions
have you ever tried organizing 10 people
into taking Swift decisions well you
know I'm Greek so I can't organize
myself I have five opinions
therein lies my point opinions I think
you have a slightly higher vision of
what humans will do to left their own
devices but it doesn't have to be a
committee it doesn't have to be a
committed firstly look in the company
practical terms can you name one
Cooperative that has actually swelled in
size and become a really effective
operation okay let me tell you that the
company I'm referring to had 350
employees and 1.2 billion dollars of
Revenue a year
and worked really very well with
completely flat management so why are
why are companies copying that
because they're being gobbled up the
because you know think of
the trustee Savings Bank remember what
happened to it it was gobbled up so the
idea of cooperatives at work is well
established from the 19th century in
this country a Cooperative Banks
Cooperative supermarkets and so on that
work magnificently but in an environment
in an economic environment where you
know the the the large fish it's a
smaller fish especially you know the
smaller
um energetic fish it's happening in in
Silicon Valley all the time you know
Google and so on they are destroying
competition by buying them up so you
know that company in particular right
you have knowing no idea I mean I'm sure
you do the extent to which there were
all these attempts by big money to buy
it out and and it will it will go
separate issue that's a separate issue
because you're basically arguing two
things on the one hand you have the
question of what's the best way to
organize a bunch of people who want to
be in business and get money to fund
that should they sit around as a happy
cooperative and sing Kumbaya it doesn't
have to be happy it's not going to be
happening
but that's one question I.E how do they
get money to finance what they're doing
and the second question then is is there
a regulatory structure to create a Level
Playing Field that stops the winners
from essentially taking all and buying
up the other so two separate questions
and I would agree on the second point
that absolutely we need better umpires
to create regulatory structures that
stop winners taking all and doing unfair
competition it comes back to my four
points for Alan Smith on the question of
how to organize companies
um yes cooperatives can sometimes work
yes I happen to think that with digital
technology probably is getting easier to
organize that than before and digital
transparency is changing things
radically and I think in many ways maybe
the savior of capitalism and I can talk
about that if you want however I happen
to think that in most cases the ability
to raise outside money from people who
have a stake in the company which is
called an equity Market is a pretty
efficient way of doing it unless and I
would agree with you unless you have
central banks printing oodles or cash
which essentially is distorting prices
right now I don't like what the central
banks have done in recent years yeah but
you know what Jillian it can't be
otherwise we are in this situation where
now if Central Bank stopped printing
money the whole thing collapses so
you're saying you don't like capitalism
2021 version but like what I'm saying is
that that you are being completely
utopic in you I think you talk
absolutely you're being your topic well
[Laughter]
let's be a topic in in a reality
why it wasn't YouTube the idea for
instance the idea
topic sounds much trendy than Utopia
is more realistic than yours but the
idea of going back to a capitalism that
works is absolutely impossible now and
you mentioned you said you talked about
the importance of having umpires of
improper regulation it's impossible they
will always be captured because the
concentration of power now and that is
what I call technophil delivery is
always going to be so gigantic that
there is no government on this planet
however well-meaning it's functionaries
that can do it this is why I'm saying
that if you really want competition and
freedom and liberalism to be given a
chance we need to move away from share
markets we need to go to a system where
uh you ask the question where does the
capital come coming from from savings we
need to do that which at Adam Smith
recognized because Adams was exactly on
my side here he was totally against
public limited companies because he
understood that the moment you have
liquid ownership you have the ownership
split up in tiny little pieces that can
be traded anonymously in the stock
exchange suddenly
his prerequisites for a well-functioning
competitive market are gone
so why not just have Pension funds
automatic enrollment to have people
owning asset you know mutual funds and
things like that providing some of the
fuel for investing in companies and then
combine that with radical digital
transparency so that people can actually
track what companies are doing and
actually Express an idea of vote if they
want to I'm going to move because the
Pension funds are taken over the Pension
funds will always be taken over by those
who happen to have a greater
um percentage so why not ownership than
others I mean look look at you know the
three big you know State streets of
Vanguard and so on the control 90 of the
New York Stock Exchange so you know who
controls them so why not work on
reforming the Pension funds and getting
better Financial oversight and
Regulation and working with a system
that appears to actually many ways spark
Innovation and growth it can be done
better but why not work with that rather
than a spa for something which has never
actually materialized anywhere in the
world on any scale effectively Brazilian
capitals never materialized anywhere in
the world until it did
thank you
nice save it for the Q a you're going to
be first
it's always good to know there's someone
in the audience and in any case I'm
arguing that your capitalism is already
evolving a bit I want to move us on
because I think we're in danger perhaps
on the markets and models I just put a
bit of a squeeze on Julian on on one
point that I've heard and this is the
problem the big Tech monopolies and what
that means I mean just to remind
ourselves the unprecedented levels of
growth and consolidation yeah so what
are you going to do about yeah well it's
about Facebook because what I'm saying
is you know corporate law which says one
employee one share that kills off the
power of Facebook what is your proposal
behave
right gosh
beautiful um just in your way
what I was thinking about what you said
about the regulator which was an
interesting thought but look there's an
example Julie how many people aiming in
people in America and elsewhere run
around in circles saying we need better
regulation that attack companies Mark
Zuckerberg doesn't give a anyway it just
doesn't happen this and to this point I
think Giannis is right to be pushing on
this it would appear to be an area which
is immune to the sort of reformist
regulatory okay let me give my answer to
Facebook what I do about Facebook and
it's different from what you expect
there's one thing that Adam Smith got
totally wrong in fact several things but
here's the most important thing for
today
he thought that barter was an
old-fashioned prehistoric practice that
really just involved cavemen sitting
around in caves swapping piles of
berries for meat and he presumed that
barter would essentially die out once he
invented money and credit
he was a hundred percent wrong
economists automatically assume that
barter is old-fashioned and doesn't
matter anthropologists and I don't know
if there are any anthropologists here
tonight this is your moment
anthropologists know that barter is
actually something which has often been
around in many communities at the same
time as money and credit anyone who's
read David graber's wonderful book Debt
the first 5 000 years will know this but
also it's going to help us with the text
I'm going to tell you Sparta is alive
and well today big time because Silicon
Valley actually runs off barter the
wholesale swap of data for services that
is a Bedrock of much of the tech sector
today it does not involve money and we
have no way of talking about it day to
day except to say that it's free
and we tend to only focus on one aspect
of this which is how tech companies take
our data we don't look at the services
the reason I say this is important
because actually we're missing a lot of
things that are happening in the economy
today and also in terms of corporate
valuations we're also missing something
that I would expect if I was to go to
all of you in the room today and say
would you like to pay for your services
that you get from Google Facebook your
email would you like to use money to buy
all that
and in exchange they can't take your
data or they'll pay you for it you might
say well yes for privacy reasons but I
guess that many of you would actually
say you know what I don't want the
hassle of having to use money to pay for
it I like getting free services
so the reason I mention all this is
really important
if you want to reform Tech today and
create a more ethical Tech system you
don't necessarily need to abolish barter
you need to change the terms of trade of
barter
and that means essentially giving
consumers more power in that bar to
trade which involves one more
transparency about how data is being
used
more transparency about what the
companies are doing inside the company
with your data and most crucially and
this comes back to the power of Market
forces
data portability
if we had the ability to pull our data
out of any tech company and go somewhere
else
we'd actually have the beginnings of a
proper Market
for our service for our us as customers
if you put the owner on tech companies
to guarantee data portability
then you'd get the beginnings of a
proper market and I'll say two more
things quickly I think that competition
would be more effective in giving
Consumers power and actually saying you
know what I hate what Facebook has done
so I'm going to pull my data away and go
somewhere else
then it would actually be in terms of
Regulation and there is a model for it
already and it's called Finance if you
change your bank account today the onus
is on the bank to ensure that your money
goes from One bank to another it's not
on you you don't have to go into it
basically physically you know get your
pile of cash out and put it to another
bank that company is required to move
the move your money that is what we
should have for tech companies today
along with better oversight along with
looking at breaking up platform control
and monopolies in terms of vertical
platforms but actually that is why
consumer power and competition matters
convinced
yes and no let me start with another
okay I'll take that as a B plus well you
know that's what you get with when you
have an economist on the one hand on the
other hand remember what Truman said I
want the one-handed economist
um
I'm convinced that we need to change
property rights over data over personal
data so here we are on and actually in
in my topic
um other now you'll find that there is a
system called okay and if you haven't
seen it I'm going to show you just
um
there is a you know I I describe various
systems one is you know how banking
would work in my socialist market system
and also how data should work and I have
a system where
came up with the the label a penny for
your thoughts so you know tiny micro
payments that are automatically made by
people so that they can also own their
own data so we're on on the same page on
this but what you're suggesting is not
going is not doing anything about the
power of Facebook anything about the
power of Amazon because let's face it
the reason why people are on Facebook is
because everybody answers in Facebook so
it's economies of scale and economies of
scope and there is nothing you can do
about that by changing the you know yeah
you have one more thing teenagers on
Facebook do you have kids teenagers
wouldn't be seen dead on Facebook
Fashions changed surprisingly fast okay
whatever I mean the people who are on
Tick Tock Beyond Tick Tock because the
people they follow are on Tick Tock so
this these are the the network economies
which you understand very well and when
it comes to Amazon
there is this technological structure
that supports a whole economy that is a
non-market and based on Power and
there's nothing you can do about that if
you stick to the idea of liquid property
that is owned and traded in share
markets I want to bring a second house
and of course feel free to come back to
this so we just
of themes perhaps before we get to
questions it would be very remiss I
think on the road to cop26 not to talk
about parole planet Earth and the impact
of capitalism on
planet Earth and whether you think
Julian the green growth is possible I
know you're a big if you can be a big
cheese can you be a big cheese in ESG a
big environmentally friendly produced
cheese in this area suggests that you do
believe in green growth but there are
many reasons how they're not if we look
around the planet today and man-made
global warming to say that capitalism
has played a very negative role in that
and to be rather skeptical yep I'd come
back to the fourth part of the Alan
Smith framework I laid out about the
need to have a shared ethical moral
legal vision and above all else a theme
that I go on about in my book which is
the need to move from tunnel vision to
lateral Vision most of the tools that we
developed in the late 20th century to
make sense of the world like economic
models apologies the honest because I
know Economist but these lovely economic
models these lovely corporate balance
sheets these lovely big data sets are
all very bounded and marked by tunnel
vision you don't have to apologize
because I agree with you
I was trying to needle you but um but
they basically treat everything that
isn't inside the economic model or the
balance sheet as an externality or a
footprint something outside that model
and what I would argue is that one of
the things that went very badly wrong
with a lot of the corporate vision and
the economic models was treating the
environment as an externality they
ignored who was going to pay for the
damage that was created or the cost of
the natural resources they were it's
quite a big floor in the capitalist
argument then well if you could actually
start measuring that and putting that
into your model so you start to get a
very different vision of
how companies are valued how they're
looking at the world there are ways of
doing that and people are developing
that impact weighted accounting
impact-rated accounting yes
the regulation that you are never going
to be able to have as long as power is
so heavily concentrated
um let me give you an example because um
I think we didn't manage the meat and
this Hammer because uh half of Greece
because everything you just turned me
down no because half of Grace burned
down and I was going from this by the
way you know that exactly is what
happened actually in Venice just to not
be right and you missed you missed you
missed an important part of my CV in
these days you know I lead the political
party in Greece you presented me as if
I'm an author and professional I did
that that's a previous life
the reason why I mentioned the the the
the the
speaking of green girls okay
um I also believe that in in green girls
but I also believe in green growth there
are things that need to grow and things
that need to dig out like we need less
cement less CO2 less of all the toxic
derivatives the toxic fumes right we
need fewer of those fewer cars whether
they're electric or not more public
transport
uh
but going back to the forest fires in
Greece this summer
Greece is a failed state right but
nevertheless when it comes to profit
making it's very fast so the day after
we were devastated and the Flames died
down
large corporations came
and took over the attempt to prevent
those uh forests from becoming mud baths
with the first rains so you think oh
that's a good thing they came to to help
Shore up the you know the soylents and
all that
first thing they did was to offer
contracts to the local population that
effectively signed all their rights away
for 20 euros a day
forget that that's
you could expect that the second thing
they did was they are trying to win
new contracts for replanting the forests
using genetically modified trees
that will glow very quickly and they
will give them the opportunity to in in
the context of the green transition
Harvest biomass for the purposes of you
know Green energy
if we allow them to do this
you're going to have under the cover of
green growth you can have the
devastation of the Flora and the Fauna
of the land and the conversion of these
areas in every and so on into victims of
Monsanto payer who will have genetically
poisoned the land while making it very
green now is this a green growth that we
want this is the green growth that this
market-based system not because it's a
market but because monsante is not a
market
toxic monolith let me come back to this
point again
[Applause]
as I said you are on your home pitch
there there
are numerous examples of green washing
there's numerous examples of companies
and finances using the green label to do
all kinds of egregious things that I
wouldn't completely agree with however
one of the other reasons I believe in
competition is that I believe in checks
and balances and I don't think we can
sit there and Trust government alone to
turn us green
when back in the 1970s when Milton
Friedman developed his vision of
shareholder capitalism which I do not
agree with there were two things that
were very different one back then people
thought that they could Outsource the
really difficult decisions in life the
social stuff to governments and
companies just worried about their
balance sheets and secondly you did not
have radical transparency and most
people did not know what was actually
happening inside companies today we have
a world where no one actually trusts the
government to get stuff done
and we have a world where all of you
have cell phones with extraordinary
levels of access to information if you
choose and many aspects of corporate
life are subject to radical transparency
the reason that you know so quickly
about what was happening in those
forests was precisely because of this
radical transparency so I come back to
the point
it's not an either or we don't need a
government or companies to be green or
ngos
we actually benefit by having different
groups in society doing this it is a
good thing that actually we're not just
relying on the Greek government alone to
deal with replanting those forests it's
good that we have citizens armed with
cell phones giving you the date you just
quoted and it's good that we've had
companies coming in and feeling the need
to do something about it even if they
are being essentially up driven by less
than virtuous principles and even if
some of the things they're doing are
wrong many of the things that companies
are doing today are better than they
were doing two or three decades ago so
my question to you not Giannis is this
would you wind back the clock and have
companies to go back to where they were
20 or 30 years ago would you only rely
on government the governments we have to
turn us green because look back what's
happened in the last decade it ain't
been so good one of the reasons why
companies why governments are under
pressure to come to cop26 and do
something is partly because there is a
shift in Zeitgeist amongst investors and
businesses that reflect social shifts
that comes back to radical transparency
come back on that because we then must
open up to a very patient audience quite
clearly mistaking me for first one of
those socialists that likes the state I
loaded the state in the same way that I
load monsanda and Bayer right so my my
worry Julian is that the state and those
large corporations are in cahoots
they're working together
and you know for you know I want
diversity I want people who live in
these areas to be empowered to do things
without either by your monsando
you know descending upon them and
effectively taking them over or the
state saying oh I will fix everything
for you the question is how do you
Empower communities with their necessary
Capital the necessary expertise and
leave them to their own devices in order
to do stuff
I think that that is the future the
future is for
um neither
for living neither under the thumb of
the state nor under the thumb of
corporate Capital those companies that
go in there are not going there to do
anything good because of transparency by
the way the transparency
is
an illusion because you know I'm telling
you now what most of those people know
in those areas of the forests but I can
tell you that not one television station
not one radio station not one newspaper
has ever reported on what is really
happening on the ground because they are
owned by the same corporate interests
please Flash not everyone gets a news
anymore from newspapers much as I'd love
them to do it